laird dijon brognon dévorés par les
flammes
c'était le 2 juillet dernier trois mille
mètres carrés de bâtiments détruits et
une cinquantaine de pompiers mobilisés
six mois plus tard les ravages de l'
incendie sont toujours bien visibles
mais en ce dernier week end avant noël
l'air a pu rouvrir pour accueillir les
vacanciers dans des préfabriqués
c'est la première fois que je m'arrête
dans cette aire d'autoroute c'est la
première fois oui autrement c'est
souvent comprend cette autoroute là
parce que c'est l'autoroute du soleil
quoi on a failli repartir mais
finalement ne rien aider à dzeko c'est
bien mais prendre un café tranquillement
m'a choqué quand même parce que c'est
rare sur une autoroute de voir voilà une
station brûlé c'est je crois la première
fois que je vois ça des nouveaux venus
essentiellement car l'information n'est
pas encore arrivée aux oreilles des
habitués en ce jour de grand départ vers
les pistes de ski
le trafic autrefois danse sur l'air
reste fluide ce week-end avant l'
incendie l'air de dijon brognon était un
poumon économique
sa réouverture est un cadeau anticipé
pour les commerçants et la municipalité
normalement ça devait pas se faire et
puis tout le monde s'y est mis
l'état les pompiers la commune on a fait
passer les commissions de sécurité avec
un rythme plutôt extraordinaire et on a
tenu le coup et ça c'est bon bien sûr
pour l'entreprise c'est bon aussi pour
la collectivité parce que la fiscalité
le redémarre il faudra être patient pour
que l'air montre un nouveau visage
le permis de construire vient d'être
signé les locaux flambant neufs de dijon
brognon à mi chemin entre le luxembourg
et marseille sortiront de terre d'ici un
an